Okay. So let's um add uh attention to
our sick to seek model
for a very simple example that uh we can
cook along the way and we want to see
how it allow the decoder to have a
differentiable access to all of these
encoder states. Okay. So for this I'm
going to
assume um a very simple minimal reverse
task meaning that let's say we have an
input of uh
integers let's say x1
x2 dta until xt and then uh we want to
learn how to reverse this. So given an
input like that we want the neural
network to learn uh the reversal task.
Okay. So the reverse will be t minus one
dot x1 until end of the sentence. Okay.
So this is basically like the contract
that uh we want to have the model solve.
So why reverse? because well the first
output depends on the last input which
requires a long range dependency.
Somehow it stresses the fixed size
bottleneck and showcases showcases how
and showcases how attention
removes this bottleneck. Okay.
So just to do a recap uh we have uh data
pooling using attention let's say an
alpha going to get alpha from somewhere.
Okay. So let's do a recap on uh the
formulation of attention. uh we are
going to do the simplest possible form
of that and then maybe along the way we
can tweak it as we learn data pooling um
that learns its uh similarity between
the date it's here the query or the
decoder state and the keys or encoder
state and this way after the softmax we
get this waitings and using this waiting
we have this weighted sum at the values
and then we use alpha for this weighted
sum that gives us the context uh that we
will use for the next decoder state. So
remember that we call this c in a
formulation and uh to compute a we use
the scale.product product that recall
that we also had a rotation on Q and K
using WQ and WV WK let's import some
modules and then we'll set up the this
problem that we discussed here okay so
let's make the
um a simple example or data let's say of
20 possible different integers so we are
looking at vocabulary size of I need um
let's give a pipe token of um zero. So
this is the token for the paddings.
Since this a seek to seek, we will have
padding in the cases that the number of
uh input sequence is less than the
maximum sequence size. Okay. So let's
have a start of sequence token.
Let's just give it a vocap size plus two
plus one here which basically we we make
it 21 and an end of sequence token plus
two and we have a max length um
basically what I mean the total
vocab size
which here will be wap size plus three
and note that that yes we are working
with this um integers but we could
easily had uh text for example or words
that we we wanted to do the reversal uh
but here we don't want to deal with the
text processing tokenization vocabulary
building we just basically generate this
random sequences and NLP aspects is not
of our interest for now okay so these
are this is the uh dimensions of each
RNN cell that we'll need together for
the encoder and decoder. So we are
looking at a 32 two-dimensional
uh hidden state or embedding that will
be
carried over in this RNN cells and let's
use uh GRU cells and um we are making um
1,500
number of samples or training pairs
and uh the batch size 64 number of
epochs 80 and let's assume in two
different cases. Let's uh one time we
train we can train this uh architecture
with a short sequence of size five and
then one time with a longer sequence of
size 20 which is much more difficult. So
these are the two possible sequences
that we want the model to handle. Let's
make a data set class that makes this
example pairs with shape handling and um
tokenization that we discussed. So this
here is the class
and for example if you want to sample
the short sequences or long sequences we
can do it using this. So now we have the
the data set for the short and long
sequences. For example, if you want to
look at the the first example in short
sequence, here is the example.
So we get uh we take in this value. This
is token 21 which is the start of
sequence and then the reversal. So if
you assume that we have this decoder
output. Okay. So let's make the vanilla
encoder something that you already know.
So I will be fast and just include the
code. So this here is the our encoder
which is a GRU
and we know how it works. So let's write
the decoder and here is the decoder same
GRU cell RNN. Okay. So during the
training of course we are using teacher
forcing meaning that we are using the
ground truth token instead of the
model's prediction but that's uh not
possible during the inference. So that
ground truth token we call it gold
tokens. Just remember if you heard that.
Okay. So and remember that here the
decoder state takes in the entire
sequence. This makes uh uh some um
optimization behind the scene. It's not
really parallelization.
Basically it it's much better than a for
loop.
um the real parallelization will happen
later when we go to self attention and
transformers. So that's the decoder. Now
let's uh write the seek to seek class.
So class uh vanilla seek to seek which
has the encoder and decoder and and this
is the forward methods. Okay, great. So
with that let's implement the seek to
seek with attention. So first we need to
write the attention mechanism
scale.product attention. Okay. So for
that let's write the class attention
mechanism.
So we compute the scores and then we
compute the softmax
weights and then we do the kernel
regression for the context. In this case
of RNN V happens to be the same as the
hidden state. Okay. So here I note that
I used an implicit WV. It's not really
necessary here.
Okay. So with that the init
we need hidden dimension and just
simplify the syntax. I know that I told
you to do the good practice, but here
don't want a screen splash. I want you
to pay attention to what matters at this
point. So, we need WQ, which is a
linear. Remember, this is just a
rotation. It's not a fine
transformation. And another linear for W
K. And same deal. Like I said, I don't
really need this, so let's just forget
that for now. We are opting for
simplicity.
We need the scaling which is basically
this variance stabilization that we
discussed. So, so we need a float output
of npubr
pen dimension. So, this is like I said
that one over u square root of dk. Good.
So, let's write the forward method.
Um we have the query Q and the cheese.
And
with that remember a query is uh the
current decoder state of size batch and
hidden uh keys is of course uh the
sequence length and we return the
context of size batch and hidden and
then at the end
weight which is the size of batch and uh
sequence input sequence length.
So we are returning not just this we are
also returning the context. So what I
mean is this. So the context
which is the kernel regression and then
we are doing it for the number of
encoder states. Okay let's call it
attention weights.
Um, here we have that. Um, just to be in
line with what I said at the beginning,
I'm going to just call it Q and K. But
this is really the uppercase Q and K in
the notes. Okay. So, we have a 2D tensor
Q and a 3D tensor K.
And now we want to compute the matrix
multiplication.
But we want to use batch matrix
multiplication which requires uh tensors
of the same dimension. So with that I'm
going to just add another dimension here
in a safe way. We know how to do it
using unsqueeze. So let's do it. And
this will return this and then we can do
batch matrix multiplication using uh
torch bmm. So torch bmm will give us the
scores. So this is scores and um this is
basically what we were wishing for the
inner product in a uh the most efficient
way that capitalize all of this
resources that we have right okay so how
to get the attention weights we
basically do the soft max we doing it
from the functional from the scores and
we do the soft max over dimension two so
remember the dimension of T maybe it's
good to explain why here. So uh here in
this uh scores when we do the batch math
mall so we basically do a multiplication
of tensor of size this with a tensor of
size
which returns tensor of size B1 and G.
So this will return tensor of size. This
this is another matal f sizing batch t
in h which returns h one h right okay
great so that's the context and we can
basically return the squeeze version of
them. So remember that we only unsqueeze
for the batch multiplication. Uh that's
the attention mechanism. We're done with
that. We just need to write the encoder.
Uh so like I said, I need an encoder
that returns all of this hidden states.
Let's call it attention encoder even
though there's no attention really
within this. We just return everything
for the attention decoder. Okay. So it's
basically the same thing just returns
all of the Okay, I added some
commentation for you. Um okay, now let's
write uh attention decoder. Here
in this class, we want to basically do a
one-step decoder attention. I mean at
each step, if you remember indexed by t,
we want to form a query from the current
decoder hidden state which is h t minus
one. And we want to compute attention
weights over encoder outputs. And then
using that tension weights we
concatenate the computed context T and
the embedding T giving we give it to the
GRU cell and predict the next token
distribution from this output T and
context T. So I will write this down. So
this is basically what we are trying to
do and with that let's write the init.
We need the hidden dimension
self embedding.
Remember we have this total
vocabulary size. We have the hidden
dimension. Oops. And then let's write
the self attention
which is an attention mechanism says a
hidden deu
cells.
Okay, looks good.
And then we have the FC that requires an
input of size hidden dimension multiply
by two. Now let's write the forward.
What we have? We have X hidden encoder
outputs. Great.
And what's X is basically the current
input token. Uh hidden is the previous
decoder state.
And the encoder outputs is basically all
of these encoder states. And we want to
return the logits the hidden everything
at time t logits hidden and attention
weights. Okay. So like I said we need
the embedding. We are using the current
in decoder state as our query B and H.
Remember that still we need to do the
concatenation and um of course we have
to take care of that. Okay. So that's
the query and now we have the query, we
have the embedding, we can pass it to
our attention. Okay, we have it here.
Great. So query encoder outputs
PHPT
that's correct. Let's just simplify this
is the context
and uh this attention weight.
Now we want to concatenate the token emo
embedding with this context right and
that will be the gru input. Okay we have
it here
cat
embedding. Oh
now that we have this rna input we can
advance one grru step. So we have to
concatenate the output and the context
and then send them to the feed forward
predictor. So first um let's call this
the prediction input which is this
output and here you see an unsque quiz
to make sure they are they have the same
dimensions and then we pass this to the
feed forward or FC the fully connected
prediction head predicts the token.
Okay. And the output is the logits at
time t.
And then we are returning the hidden and
attention weight. So we have everything
to write our class. The class of
attention seek to seek
what we have here. Great. And then just
like before a def code decode. Okay.
Have that too. Okay. So let's do the
training. Remember the training is with
teacher forcing. What I mean is uh we
feed the true previous token to the
decoder during the training. Uh but of
course we don't have that at inference
time. The last will be the token level
cross entropy over the entire t+1
decoder steps of course including the
end of sequence token. So we have to
make sure in the cross entropy loss we
will ignore the padding tokens. Uh
that's the only thing that we should
take care of. Okay. So with that let's
write the train model. So we taking in
model let's pass the learning rate too.
So with that um just to write what I
mean here about the train uh with the
teacher forcing. Okay. So now the
optimizer um let's do add
okay so takes in model parameters
learning rate okay criteria and cross
entropy of course we got this as a
suggestion that's great
um before train just make sure you're
sending it to device that's that uh
loader is the data loader and that takes
in the data set we have the batch size
and everything. So let's just use that
shuffle true. We don't need this. Okay.
For epochs, let's before writing this
just make sure we have empty list for
recording the accuracies and also time
let's do time. Okay. So for epoch in
range we need the epoch loss to start
epoch loss and correct and total we need
to initiate this values. So our
recording we want to initiate this for
keeping the tally. Okay. four source
target input target output in loader we
have source stat
device and then optimizer no gra zero
grad so let's uh because I want to uh
run this in two different ways of
attention and no attention let's define
an is attention instance here let's do
it here so is attention
is an instance. The model is attention
seek to seek. If is tension basically
run the modeling code uh once per batch
and then we want to do stepbystep
decoding and to do that let's accept
this and simplify then
press which we need to populate like I
said in a stepbystep decoding so for t
in range
Um this requires a teacher forcing a
token. So I have to first get the token
to use it instead of this which happens
in during the inference of course. But
here for the training we have to do
teacher forcing. Okay. So that's that
that good and now else the venda seek to
seek remember. So in this case hidden
encode source here we are just leaving
living leaving living leaving living it
to pietorch gru that does everything at
basically decodes the force sequence in
parallel so it does itself we don't need
to do anything did I forget something so
for t this that's the pred
we have to output something here right
so output cat pres one which will be F
size B the decode sequence and we now
going back here the output here
is the output of the decoder and let's
accept this and that's that and this is
of the same size we're done with that
part now we have to compute the loss we
got the suggestion and okay view output
shape target output so this is basically
cross entropy over all of these time
steps. We flatten batches and times and
we do the loss backward and then
optimizer. We can for example clip the
the gradient here before the step.
Right? Let's record the epoch loss and
uh let's look at the token accuracy. So
epoch class uh let's first compute the
predicted
token
which is a size batch and the uh the
decoder sequence and let's mask the the
paths and let's compute the corrected
correct predictions. We may have a error
here but let's accept this for now and
then so where's if total
it's not zero we should be careful here
so then we can append that uh I had the
epoch loss so let's just record loss too
that's that we just need to return the
accuracies um let's actually add some
verbos uh to just show the the epoch
classes and the token accuracy uh when
it finish the timing of that and then we
will return the accuracy. So I'm going
to add that. Let's run this. In the
meantime, we can write a function for
evaluation.
Basically, we want to evaluate the the
sequence with a greedy decoding meaning
that we don't have any teacher forcing
anymore, right? We require the exact
match of the entire t+1 length sequence
even including the end of sequence.
Right? I assume you know this function
because you wrote this in the
assignment. Then I will write evaluation
and some visualization code. I also
included a plotting
uh that uh basically shows the
comparison of this um evaluation. What
else? We can also write um a function
that visualize the attention. Why this
is interesting? Because I I want to show
that how tension manages to to look way
back in the past to align the first
decoder state to the first encoder
state. So first let's look at this.
We see that attention works
perfect in the in the case of short
sequences. I had some errors in how to
how I'm uh recording the the token
accuracy. So I have to revisit that. But
the the sequence accuracy we see here.
Uh we are not doing well in the vanilla
for long sequences because of that issue
the bottleneck issue that uh is the
worst in this case. it has to look back
20 states back to be able to uh
understand the reversal. We don't have
that issue with attention here. You see
that I made an error here to go back and
fix it. But for now, let's rely on this.
And I want to also this attention
patterns and let's do it.
So basically we one example and we
visualize the tension weights. Okay, I
will share the code with you. This is
just we just need to if we run the
visualization weights it will return a
fe. So big
visual.
Okay. So if we do it basically the input
sequence uh output sequence. So input is
24 1947
until 16 and the output 165 and looked
at uh the the first output is looking at
the first input. So this is basically a
long range attention that we are talking
about. Basically it's the the max out
length right it's instead of that
diagonal here we have the other
diagonal. We will look at the purely
attentionbased neural networks. We drop
even the RNN and we use self attention
to do the encoding.